I'm not a socialist myself I'm a social
just to be clear I'm I don't I'm not
advocating for social media okay I don't
know that many actual socialists like
who would who where's the big desire for
the U.S to become socialists if you look
at the Democratic party there's almost
no socialism
Communist party now it's just one that's
one socialist idea from the Democratic
party um uh socialized Health Care no
that's a social social democracy program
no it's Denmark Socialist and if you
notice that Barack Obama
the Fallen Messiah you know he's the
father Messiah right I don't know
anything about that well I beat Mama
Michelle uh he tried to turn America
into a socialist society what's one
example of a socialist policy that he
had uh socialized Health Care he didn't
do that he did before profit Obamacare
taking care of everybody how so uh by
getting rid of jobs many people mostly
took care of people by getting rid of
full-time jobs and they had to work two
part-time jobs in order to survive so
you don't even understand the talking
points